regardons paris de plus chez moi je me
suis demandé est ce que jeff bezos
l'homme le plus riche du monde pourrait
s'offrir tout ça s'il voulait construire
une ville aussi immense depuis zéro le
pourrait-il financièrement vous reposer
un petit exercice de mathématiques en
essayant d'estimer le coût d'une ville
notons vraiment acheté une ville la
réponse oui et c'est plutôt utile et le
musk la sphère xp 6 il faisait des tests
de fusées près d'un village au texas
mais le souci c'est qu'un décollage
c'est violent pour arranger tout le
monde
elon musk a décidé d'acheter toutes les
maisons du village au triple de leur
valeur un total de 8,5 millions de
dollars comme ça il n'y aura plus de
locaux et les tests de spe 6 ne
remettrait plus personne certains ont
refusé et à ce jour il ne reste plus que
neuf habitants qui résiste à l'offre et
au bruit mon histoire n'est pas aussi
sombre car la présence de l'entreprise
en a fait un lieu touristique et grâce à
cela les villes voisines se développe
énormément pas tout le monde a cette
chance
par exemple vous allez pierre cardin qui
a acheté une ville médiévale dans le
vaucluse où il a rénové plus d'une
cinquantaine de propriétés sauf que il y
à un piège il ne les loups jamais la
raison l'artiste ultra-riches le dit
dans un interview certains
collectionnent les timbres ou les
chevaux de course
moi c'est les maisons c'est ainsi que la
ville se retrouve privé deux familles de
commerce et de terres agricoles
les habitants impuissants fui petit à
petit les lieux quelques-uns ont même
fait un documentaire afin de dénoncer
cette pratique
même chose pour le célèbre acteur johnny
depp qui a acheté le village de plan de
la tour à 27 kilomètres de saint tropez
75 millions de dollars pour avoir une
vie au calme à l'abri des caméras la
ville possède actuellement deux piscines
un gymnase un parc de skate des
vignobles et un bistrot si vous êtes
intéressé à cause de son divorce il
compte la revendre au prix de 55 5
millions de dollars une affaire hdm
gilles peut aussi être l'occasion de
faire des 10 des all you tube
oui il ya des youtuber spécialisé là
dedans comme brender woods qui a acheté
le village de serre gordo en californie
pour 1,4 million 2
dollars toutes ses économies pour un
rêve de gosse à voir son visage de
cowboy et pouvoir y mourir
d'ici là il faut tout rénové et vous
pouvez suivre ces galères sur youtube
maintenant si vous tenter cette aventure
en france c'est possible il y à des
sites et des sections dédiées à la vente
de ville sur ebay 1 6 pour cent
cinquante mille euros vous pouvez
acheter la ville de bodin dans le jura
le hic c'est que les maisons sont trop
vieille et que les rénovations sont
estimées à bam 2 millions d'euros à l'as
tout de suite va falloir faire beaucoup
de vue combien coûte paris on va essayer
d'estimer ça ensemble
le prix moyen d'un appartement et de
10000 34 euros du mètre carré
on put à la superficie de la ville et
205 kilomètres carrés mais on peut pas
calculer comme ça déjà y aller parc les
lacs les routes mais il ya surtout les
étages pour ce qui est des rues des
parcs et les cours d'eau on connaît leur
superficie globale qui souffre il
soustraire on a donc 52 kilomètres de
surface bâtie sable maintenant il faut
compter les étages ce qui est facile à
paris puisque les immeubles font à peu
près tous la même taille 60 % d'entre
eux sont des immeubles haussmanniens qui
suivent des règles architecturales
précise avec une hauteur maximale de 20
mètres sur 7 étages
c'est pas fini il reste encore un
problème à résoudre dans un immeuble
haussmannien il y à des cours
intérieures et à sion n'a aucune donnée
alors on voit quelques laisse à nous
mêmes
voici une photo d'un endroit au hasard
dans paris faudrait pouvoir trouver le
pourcentage de bâtiments et de cours ce
qui nous permettrait d' estime
approximativement combien ça représente
alors comment on va faire d'après vous
on a réfléchi longuement et on a bricolé
un petit truc on va colorisées les
routes les cours et les bâtiments en
trois couleurs différentes qu'on va
passer dans un petit logiciel qui permet
de savoir combien de pixels de couleurs
il ya dans une image on trouve 60% de
bâtiment va pour sand route 20% cours on
a donc 32 kilomètres carrés fois entre
cinq et sept étages en moyenne on peut
approximer 190 kilomètres de surface
habitable en retirant les murs les
couloirs par rapport à ce que j'ai pu
constater dans mon propre immeuble
on devrait être à 150 kilomètres carrés
pour vérifier le chiffre on allait sur
l'insee mais on n'a aucune donnée
précise que des moyennes mais ça reste
pas si éloigné du chiffre qu'on a
il suffit alors de multiplier avec le
prix d'une
car les moyens du coup dans votre agence
immobilière paris vaut mille cinq cents
milliards d'euros et c'est pas fini
parce que le problème à paris-xiii cas
aussi des monuments historiques
par exemple la tour eiffel qui est
estimé à 4 134 milliards d'euros le
musée du louvre 7,5 milliards le palais
de l'elysée 1,2 milliard on arrive
facilement à 2000 milliards d'euros pour
s'acheter paris faut savoir que des
économistes ont essayé de faire la même
chose que nous et sans compter les
bureaux sans compter les monuments il
estime paris à 706 milliards d'euros de
logements
juste pour habiter dans le classement
vous avez en deux marseille pour 82
milliards d'euros nice pour 58 ou
bordeaux pour 33 milliards d'euros
du coup même jeff bezos seul homme le
plus riche du monde avec toute sa
fortune
ils ne pourraient s'acheter que 20 % des
logements de paris bon il pourrait se
consoler en achetant tout l'immobilier
de marseille et de bordeaux
si vous trouvez ça un peu cher vais
construire une ville de +0 totalement
votre image en plein milieu de la nature
c'est ce qui s'est passé pour brasilia
la capitale du brésil qui a été
construite ex nihilo en 1960 il a fallu
quarante et un mois de travaux et 83
milliards de dollars pour la construire
on a aussi le projet né homme du prince
haïti mme ahmed bin salle même en arabie
saoudite
une ville qui fera 250 fois la taille de
paris sans voiture ni rue ni émissions
de carbone et qui coûtera 500 milliards
de dollars
par contre c'est magnifique si vous
trouvez ça encore trop cher à vous
n'êtes pas au bout de vos surprises
parce que ce qui coûte le plus cher dans
une ville c'est l'entretien
combien ça coûte d'entretenir une ville
aux états unis les nz benson a voulu
vivre son rêve acheter une ville dans le
dakota du sud et en devenir le chef
malheureusement le rêve a tourné au
cauchemar et la ville a été reprise par
la banque
vendu pour 250 mille dollars mais que
s'est il passé
il n'y avait pas grand chose à
entretenir juste l'équivalent de trois
terrains de foot de prairies et quelques
bâtiments bon le gars il a eu un divorce
et les gens qui habitent et son parti
pensant la ville hantée bref il était
ruiné il faut savoir que l'état lui même
vous dépanne avec un peu d'argent pour
gérer votre vie
vos récompenses ensuite pour votre
statut de mère avec une somme d'argent
une sorte d'indemnisation pour le temps
que vous avez sacrifié plus votre ville
comporte d'habitants plus cette somme
est importante par exemple dans les
villes de paris lyon marseille
les maires gagnent environ 8400 euros
mais en bas de l'échelle les maires de
petits villages eux ne gagne qu environ
650 euros brut par mois
le problème c'est que vous avez le
devoir d'assurer la sécurité des
habitants à commencer par la route
pour vous donner une idée regardez ces
chiffres pourtant ce n'est pas ce qui
coûte le plus cher
car oui vous devez aussi maintenir la
loi aux etats unis les villes sans
police deviennent des squats dangereux
il faut aussi réussir à faire venir les
médecins privés ou sinon construire des
hôpitaux publics et tout ça et grimper
les prix autre chose vitale l'eau et
l'électricité sinon vos habitants ne
font pas long feu
et rien que pour 1 km de lignes à haute
tension ces deux des regrets un million
d'euros alors ok vous pouvez toujours
privatiser ses services pour vous
faciliter la tâche
mais sachez qu'il y a souvent des
problèmes financiers par exemple en
argentine
il y avait une entreprise privée à
coller au hadj latino pour gérer le
service postal
le souci c'est qu'il fonctionnait à
perte malgré les aides de l'état
du coup ils ont décidé de tout arrêter
et le service postal est redevenu public
ce phénomène est très courant par
exemple des villes comme grenoble
briançon et nice reprennent le service
d'eau et d'énergie ou encore barcelone
qui reprend le service funéraire l'un
des rares qui a fonctionné c'est la
ville de trélazé qui refuse d'avoir des
policiers à la place ils ont fait appel
à des équipes de surveillance de nuit et
ont installé des caméras s'y maintenir
les services est si important c'est
surtout parce que ça ai dit vos citoyens
de partir imaginez votre ville sans
police sans médecin et sans école
beaucoup de familles partiront pour
s'installer dans des villes mieux
fournis et si vous n'avez pas assez
d'habitants c'est vos services qui
partiront à leur tour c'est ce manque
d'activité économie d'accessibilité aux
services et à une qualité de vie qui
provoque par exemple la désertion des
médecins de petite-île un fléau
du coup il existe des petites villes
comme dans la sartre qui sont prêts à
payer le prix
or pour garder leur médecin 8000 euros
brut pour 35 heures de travail en 2020
un français sur dix ont des difficultés
à accéder aux soins
on a également la désertion des écoles
plus d'un tiers des villes en france ne
peuvent pas fournir d'éducation aux
enfants je suis allé voir le coût de
l'entretien et le maintien des services
des grandes villes
je savais que tout ça était cher mais
j'étais très loin du compte par exemple
pour paris rien qu'en 2019
ils ont dépensé au total 6,9 milliards
d'euros pour faire fonctionner leurs
propres services publics
on peut se dire que c'est normal car il
y à beaucoup plus de monde et qu'il faut
rapporter la dépense au nombre
d'habitants a même à ce niveau paris
reste la ville la plus dépensière de
france avec ses 2700 6 euros annuels par
habitant dans le top 20 on retrouve 17
villes d'île de france
al'inverse les plus économes son show
les brest et quimper
avec une dépense de 703 euros annuels
par habitant
du coup même si vous êtes tout seul dans
votre ville vous aurez énormément de mal
à la faire fonctionner les maires sont
d'ailleurs obligé de faire des emprunts
et donc de s'endetter
rien que pour paris l'endettement de la
ville s'élève à 6,8 milliards d'euros en
2019 et risquerait de monter jusqu'à 7,1
milliards d'euros d'ici la fin de cette
année la raison ou installer plus des
espaces verts compenser les pertes à
cause d'annulation d'événements et la
rénovation de lieux c'est en réalité un
investissement sur l'image de la ville
car elle se dégrade et paris perd
environ 11000 habitants tous les ans
depuis 2013 au final avoir une ville
s'est pas aussi bien qu'on pourrait le
croire et cela pourrait vous ruiner vous
allez devoir trouver un équilibre
fragile entre taxes et vos habitants
maintenir l'ordre et veiller à leurs
besoins et cela nous laisse penser que
les villes de demain seront totalement
différente
plus grande plus dense et plus haute
elles seront à l'image de l'homme aussi
expansive que leurs ambitions
[Musique]